bonjour un billet pour Alice Island s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
je suis Amélia je travaille aux éditions
c'est mon coup de cœur absolu c'est un
livre mineur sur la possibilité de
trouver le grand amour à n'importe quel
âge vous trouvez pas sa fantastique
pour moi pas de problème
monsieur ficré parlez-moi un peu de
votre mode de vie je suis âgé de 39 ans
je vis seul je me nourris principalement
de plats surgelés je ne suis pas ce
qu'on appelle un alcoolique mais j'aime
boire jusqu'à perdre connaissance au
moins une fois par semaine et depuis que
ma femme est morte je déteste mon
travail vous traversez une période
difficile d'accord
[Musique]
et toi
ton propriétaire de la librairie je
l'aime énormément mais je ne peux plus
m'occuper d'elle quelqu'un va devoir
s'occuper de Maya pendant le week-end
c'est que pour le weekend ça doit pas
être très compliqué
[Musique]
pourquoi tu l'as pas laissé au poste de
police je pouvais pas faire ça tu as pas
l'intention de garder ça si non
vous savez il y a quelque chose d'assez
héroïque à être libraire et c'est aussi
assez héroïque d'adopter un enfant merci
Amélia mes amis m'appellent
[Musique]
c'est parti pour la sélection d'été
c'est quoi ce bouquin quel bouquin sur
la table derrière vous si vous venez un
jour à Providence je vous le montrerai
vous n'êtes pas en train de me draguer
si
je plaisante vous avez été vraiment
méchant avec moi la première fois qu'on
s'est vu j'espère que vous auriez oublié
j'ai pas oublié j'en suis désolé parce
que je vous appréciais énormément
presque toutes les mauvaises choses dans
la vie sont le résultat d'un mauvais
timing et toutes les bonnes choses sont
le résultat d'un bon timing je viens de
finir de lire un livre que vous m'aviez
recommandé c'est spectaculaire la
prochaine fois peut-être que vous
m'écouterez quand je vous dirai qu'un
livre est le meilleur parfois les romans
ne vous rencontrent que quand c'est le
bon moment
personne ne voyage sans vrais raison
ceux qui sont perdus soit être perdus
[Musique]
tu sais ce que toutes ces années m'ont
appris qu'il vaut mieux avoir aimé et
perdu et qu'il vaut mieux être seul
qu'avec quelqu'un qui ne nous plaît pas
vraiment mais parfois j'en ai un peu
marre de toutes ces leçons
je croyais que cette journée serait plus
romantique elle est très romantique
[Musique]